- We're going to see how much you know
about this weeks pop culture.
(upbeat music)
(squeaking)
- So this week, the iPhone
8 and X were revealed.
Am I going to buy it?
Hell to the no.
- So it's $999.
- Right, and you have the choice.
You can either do like the
X, or you can do the 8.
- I love when people put
an X, so like, it's cool.
Like, hell no.
It still costs a thousand dollars.
- The way that I would be
so okay with a flip phone.
- They're asking you to
spend a thousand dollars,
but there's still no software to stop you
from texting your mother fucking ex.
- This entire phone is so extra.
- I'm nervous if I got it and
I did the facial recognition,
like there's like Kirsten
like awake and with makeup on,
and then there's Kirsten in her house
eating noodles out of a cup.
- They have like a little
bit of water resistance,
but I want like the full blown waterproof,
so I can take it in the shower.
- Oh yeah. Take that in the fucking tub.
- I feel like the key to
finding spiritual bliss
is not being a slave to the
Apple iPhone release cycle.
I released myself from that years ago,
and my skin is clear, I get
eight hours of sleep a night,
and I am feeling amazing.
(laughing)
I don't give a shit about
what iPhone you're dropping,
Steve, Tim Cook, Steve Cook, whatever.
I don't know you, I don't know her.
- Rihanna release her Fenty Beauty line,
giving literally everyone
that's ever tried
to do beauty a run for their money.
- All the black women in the world are
(clapping)
(cheering)
Thank you sis.
- As someone who doesn't
wear or buy makeup,
like, Rihanna could make me buy makeup.
- She has 40 skin tone shades.
She made such a point of
making it incredibly inclusive.
- All of these makeup
lines are releasing these,
you know, foundation colors
for dark skinned women.
And it's like, where you all been?
Dark skin women need foundation.
- I know, everyone buys makeup.
She doesn't just slap
her name on something,
she's like, I'm going to go
110%, that's why I love her.
- Darker skinned women didn't
have the makeup they needed,
and she just provided it.
Also, that fucking highlight.
- Rihanna is perfect, she can do no wrong.
I will follow her into a pit of fire.
- She just out here
making political stances
and these coins, and I
cannot even be mad at her.
- I want to see the iPhone Rihanna.
- Mic drop.
- I want Apple to release
a line of Rihanna phones.
- Yes.
- Unapologetically
black, as she should be.
- The movie IT came out
and it also introduced us
to our new gay icon, Pennywise.
- His makeup is beat to perfection.
He's got that beautiful
like flowing red hair.
- That jawline.
- The jawline, the outfits.
- I have decided to stay on
the Babadook and Pennywise.
- I'm on board, I'm on board the ship.
- They deserve each other.
- I want to know who's the top.
- I think Pennywise is the bottom.
- I do too. Charge.
- But they also might reverse.
- Listen, it's 2017,
everyone should be verse.
- Because the word on the street is that
everyone wants to fuck
Pennywise the clown.
- Right.
- Because it's played by a Skarsgård.
- When the white makeup runs off.
- He's giving me a little
bit of serial killer vibes,
at the same time, he can get it.
- Would you fuck Pennywise
in Pennywise costume
if it meant you could
be with Bill Skarsgård.
- I kind of want a little
bit of clown makeup
still on him.
- You're saying if I
fuck Pennywise one time,
I get to marry Bill Skarsgård for life.
- Yeah.
- Yes, of course.
- Alexander Skarsgård, his older brother,
he is the crown jewel of the family.
- I'm not going to be the
other man to the most iconic
gay relationship of our time.
- Right, respect that
relationship for sure.
- So it was just announced
that Selena Gomez
got a kidney transplant
from her good friend.
- She's got her friends donating kidneys,
I'm lucky when my friends text me back.
- I heard that the
Weeknd is like scheduling
his appearances around her recovery.
- Pretty much goals, other
than Pennywise and Babadook.
- Two most iconic couples
of 2017, for sure.
- Mark our words.
- So that's this week in pop culture.
I personally am hoping Rihanna's next step
in her career is taking on Ted Cruz.
- Next week I'm hoping
that Paul Ryan will like
a porno tweet involving
Pennywise and the Babadook.
- I want to see some Michael B. Jordan,
aka Michael bust it open Jordan.
- Anything Michael B. Jordan,
you'll just lap it up.
- Michael bae Jordan.
Michael Booky Jordan.
Michael baby daddy Jordan.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
- Get Kylie shook 101.
(squeaking)